why would it be CrossFit well he looks
like a cross better you didn't shave
yeah so everyone's in CrossFit well
CrossFit is like you know and when I
take CrossFit Olympic lifting you got
interval training turning them on
Instagram there's no cross we going on
what kind of workouts to you they're
just just regular lifts you know fish
military oh god do stuff like that all
right yeah yeah I don't know when you'd
CrossFitters who yeah I don't I really
don't know any crust is who trying to
think that our horse hunter or like or
athlete like or that are doing well
because I'm not being mean about it is
it's on sport or the lights are still I
don't know anyone who's just like all I
do is CrossFit yeah you always ask that
I'm like no man it's not it's really not
what people do I have their subculture
but people in shape I don't know that
they're doing at Omicron there's some
there they are studs but some new pro so
it's about my thumb the other day that
said I should do CrossFit because you
know what you do doesn't have any
redeemable qualities something like that
I think Roscoe will make you a better
athlete now I'm just like I it I don't
think so I mean just fine if you're an
athlete I mean you can't take somebody
having to crossfit also another amazing
athlete are they no I mean if you're
athletic you're athletic correct if you
can enhance what you got but CrossFit
Indiana turn you into some amazing
athlete I don't know in my opinion I
agree a hundred percent it's almost like
CrossFit if you do CrossFit this
probably not a lot of room for other
stuff you know thanks they were talking
about this like a lot of the athletes
were doing crossfit football players and
they were so tired and they were so
broken down by the time they got to
practice it wasn't really the best thing
to do do do the NFL guys do CrossFit I
haven't heard that know any like big
strength position coach colleges
anything like that they don't do they
don't do CrossFit so do circuit training
but yeah like you know that do a
thousand reps or where the hell they're
doing hospet and sports don't mix right
really don't know that's kind of you
know cuz I figure if the NFL isn't doing
it it's not making you better athlete
they're all about that money yeah these
are the NBA guys are named the best
athlete you know those guys are doing
those basic list squat and snap
tional adamant on alternate flatter your
bit of a lost cause you in all this
talent you got kind of kind of screwed
by the judges we thought Roy now so a
lot of people thought you won that fight
if you look back to season 10 a lot of
people that you want win that fight we
took I don't know if you're here you're
gonna find I don't know man meet Roy
Nelson might go on to win that [ __ ] you
know who and I had been fighting in the
finals and weird it would let her know
but who knows if you won that fight and
but you were kind of you know you're
you're that you're good of a party
animal yes we really you're like
Canada's free spirit you were young get
all the skill and then 21 at the
beginning of the filming of The Ultimate
Fighter and then 22 on there when it
released and yeah I mean I I mean you
know I dealt with a lot of substance
abuse and and I was a depressed like a
hearty I did depressed I draw in it you
don't know that Justin I bet I do he
does I you know where I'm able to train
for my fight because I got something
coming up but then whenever you guys
help me get ready for that then I fight
win or whatever I'm not there tell you
go I'm out sorry animal and that's why I
had to leave you know that's why it was
good that that I had some tough love
saying you need to go get some help and
fix your life before you come back to
this and no it's really great man on the
ultimate fighter i don't know if i told
you but I actually snuck a bunch of oxy
in there did you really need a man
person dude I like myself it's not a
disguise liked up there I would a nice
lunch right yeah hell yeah little it was
like my backup plan you know I'm gonna
win this thing but if not then I need to
erase the smell faithful yeah yeah and
so I just compiling that with a free
booze of anything you wanted so it was
trouble you don't realize like on the
shows you can write down whatever you
want you know i I've never been a
drinker or really into any other stuff
and you could write down Alaskan king
crab flaming young every night and they
were bringing it to you sometimes take a
little longer get to but if you wrote
down Jack Daniels smirnoff whatever it
would be there in minute I don't know
that you think I had it wrong yeah
they're like as you say vodka and just
could do show you home I it was like a
genie in a bottle you want liquor it was
there one food it took a little longer
we're not weird who's so nice being back
down like thing hey how about this um
both of my five days both of my sight
days on the ultimate
writer my grocery list everything on my
grocery list was gone the steel cut oats
the blueberries this and that like of my
food you know how we had our dad it was
gone I'm both days weird yeah on the
fight day they was there before and then
on flight deals guys so strange so uh
but we asked for liquor and boom it's
right there that's right you know but
here's my food its fight day I need this
it's going just booked and impossible
row that thing out just so it's [ __ ]
harsh on the eyes ah anytime there's any
negativity or is like chin you're doing
a great job yeah I asked him girl it
looks like that [ __ ] dinosaur another
one dress park that was go let's see
when I asked her what it was like that
sex the sky I knew she goes he was and I
go what he goes oh nothing and I go what
was it she goes he's just so white and
he's covered in moles well and then his
bush was so big it's like look who s
that bush's these days like it's the 80
por lo and if they got a girl goes do
you clean your butt I go I do you mean
if I'm gonna have sex sure they go young
guys are so close I go was just
sometimes you down there and they just
haven't wiped probably oh yeah I can't
follow the way she'll have to me she was
like kind sir which was horas de bulging
this evening or she was just a girl it
was like just move on oh my god like
this guy and he's just not that clean
he's just a young huh jock who doesn't
[ __ ] clean himself she's got in a
guitar and she just set up a little mic
and right there well you know where the
voodoo doughnut is in the universal
citywalk oh did you show the tribal sin
limas I'm Sun gun laws donuts line was
too long you're lying line was too long
day it was so long that they had they'd
be metal grates for you to wind around
and then there was in Second Life to
Live does he give away to realize it
does he give away though yeah Disney
Disney space mountain that's all on the
Whitley we make your wife wait for us
she was with the kids and I went and I
snuck to citywalk to get budu donuts and
I went that's a line they weren't yeah
they go you know how they go yeah yeah
hooray back there oh I'm not doing that
for donuts now I want to almost did but
I didn't see your mouth is watering on
my mouth is watering that shake your
head I would do anything
follow me know what he wonder who that
for donuts what do we know what he won't
do what it wanted yes how here do I want
to do anything for love but then you go
on have asked lay with the strange that
I won't do that yeah do we know what he
won't do I know google it denier ahead
girl that like I'll do anything I'll do
anything with you I'll do anything you
do anyone yeah can I go on in south no I
don't do that [ __ ] well [ __ ] hey man
that's naughty thing is what's with the
[ __ ] teen yeah where's the action
yeah penny I don't finish so many things
a little better you can hang with me
with an asterisk all right you mix
Donald trouble with a whisper those
weird good yeah with an ass chicks go
back to do anything I want